What are some of the most interesting projects that you've seen done with
CUDA from the beginnings, all the way until today?
Yeah, you know, one of the great parts about this job is that I continuously learn about fields of
science and computing that I had no idea existed.
Whether it be, you know, defense, or oil and gas, or finance.
One of my more favorite projects is the work being done in CT scanners.
A CT scanner is actually--I don't know if you know how this works
but it's a series of X-rays they take at different angles,
and you're taking 2D X-rays and the machine actually composits
the X-rays together and were actually, recreates the 3D model of what's going on
inside your lungs or heart or body or whatever.
While it's really cool to get that 3D vision, the bad part actually is the radiation is kind of harmful.
In fact, you want to kind of use the least amount of radiation, but the more x rays
you get the better the view of the problem you have.
So what this one group is doing is actually, they're using GPUs and they've been able to reduce the
amount of x-ray radiation by something like 20 X, really making it much safe as a procedure.
And applying the power of the GPU to take many more
lower-dosage radiation shots, and combine them together to not only get a
clearer picture with less radiation, but you get it really quickly, in one sitting.
You don't have to home and come back to figure out if you have x, y, z problem or issue.
So it's really cool to see that kind of stuff truly affecting lives.